[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC- THE GO GO'S, "WE GOT THE
BEAT"]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Please give a big hand
for Peppermint, Bonnie
Milligan, and Taylor Iman Jones.
[APPLAUSE]
Keep it going.
Yes.
Welcome, Hello.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Hello, hi.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yes, I
think we can pretty much
end after that amazing video.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Where are--
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: I'm done.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
--tickets available?
Perfect.
Welcome to Google.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Thank you.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Thank
you so much for coming.
We're so excited to have you.
Before we get started, just,
let's go down the line.
We'll start with you, Bonnie.
Just tell us about yourself
and your character in the show.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Sure,
I'm Bonnie Milligan.
And I-- oh.
hello.
Bonnie Milligan, I'm making my
Broadway debut doing this show.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
It's very exciting.
And I play one of the
princesses in this royal family
of Arcadia, Pamela.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: My
name is Taylor Jones.
And I play her royal
handmaiden in the show
who has a bit of a crush.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Back at ya.
PEPPERMINT: I'm Peppermint.
Do I need that?
No.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: No.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: No, you're good.
PEPPERMINT: I'm
Peppermint and I play
Pythio the Oracle in the show.
And it's my Broadway
debut as well.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Yes!
[HISSING]
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Believe me, we
are going to talk about this.
This is amazing.
And it's all of
your Google debuts.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Yes.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: It is.
PEPPERMINT: It is, well,
yeah, well, in person.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: It's amazing.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: I use
Google all the time.
PEPPERMINT: Yes.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: I
don't know if that--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Every time
you say it, we get $0.10,
so keep saying--
TAYLOR IMAN JONES:
Google, Google--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: --it, perfect.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES:
--Google, Google, Google.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: So this
show just gave me--
I mean, it really just
gave me so much life.
And seeing you three onstage
is just, like, such a delight.
Let's just start by talking
about these Broadway debuts.
Peppermint, obviously,
you are making history
as the first out trans person
to originate a role on Broadway.
Which is--
PEPPERMINT: A mouthful.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN: I
practiced that beforehand--
PEPPERMINT: Oh yeah?
MICHAEL SHAYAN: --perfect.
I mean, what's that like?
How did you get
involved with the show?
And just, how does
it feel to be--
PEPPERMINT: It's
a dream come true.
I mean, to make your
Broadway debut is so--
I'm on cloud 900.
And it's-- and you're right,
it is an historic moment.
And I don't take that lightly.
It just feels so great
that I have the opportunity
to audition and
actually, you know,
the drag gods were in
the world-- in the room
when I auditioned.
And I got the part.
And initially, I was just
excited to be on Broadway,
but then I had a chance to
read more into the script,
and obviously, meet
the fabulous cast.
And just the entire experience
has been great for me.
And then I'm also
really happy that there
is this historic moment,
and not only my casting,
but also in the character.
And that's not
lost on me at all.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah, tell me a
little bit about the character
and how you sort of
created this character.
How do you interpret
the character Pythio?
PEPPERMINT: I didn't
create the character, but--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: You
know what I mean.
No, I mean, like, how do you
create the character on stage.
PEPPERMINT: Oh, OK, originate--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Originate.
PEPPERMINT: Well,
the character is
Pythio who is the Oracle of
Delphi, who has, for those who
come to see the show, a
few different connections
to each cast member in the show.
And I guess it's important
to say that this show is
essentially about a
family on the run,
on a journey of self-discovery,
to say it very quickly.
And so the Oracle is
instrumental in that,
and gives some key prophecies
that are kind of dooming.
And so the Oracle themselves
identify as gender non-binary.
And so that's, I think, an
historic moment as well.
I've never heard of
any Broadway characters
self-expressing as non-binary.
And so getting into the
role, I mean, luckily
the non-binary part of it
is not very daunting for me,
just, obviously having dealt
with my own issues of gender
and kind of exploring
that myself.
But on top of it,
there's something kind
of mythical and mystical
about my character
in a very positive way.
And they're very empowered.
And they're very
powerful and in control
at every moment in the
show, which is, I think,
rare a lot of times
for queer folk,
and especially
gender-non-conforming folk who
are oftentimes the butt of
the joke, killed off way too
soon, or just like
this mythical being,
like a unicorn, which is lovely,
but we're more than that,
obviously.
So it's great to have kind
of a full circle moment.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah,
beautiful, I mean,
we will talk about
representation,
because I think it's--
I mean, on one level, just
seeing the three of you here
on this stage, just such fierce
and talented gor-- you know,
amazing--
PEPPERMINT: What?
Did you just say gorgeous, what?
Oh my god.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Six
pages of it, honey.
PEPPERMINT: OK.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: OK?
PEPPERMINT: Do you get paid
every time you say gorgeous?
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Yes!
PEPPERMINT: Gorgeous, gorgeous.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Gorgeous,
gorgeous, gorgeous, gorgeous.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Gorgeous, gorgeous.
So representation on
that level, I think,
is just, like, really beautiful.
Bonnie, we've talked
about representation
as a person of size.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Yes.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Can you talk
about your song Beautiful?
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Well, I get
to be the beautiful princess.
And everybody onstage
agrees and says, yes.
Like, I'm not a butt of a joke,
which is sadly revolutionary.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: She's the
most beautiful princess--
BONNIE MILLIGAN:
The most beautiful.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES:
--in the whole land.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: And I have
a love story, spoiler alert,
with Taylor.
And it is something that--
you don't get to see
plus size people,
A, be on stage without
being, like, I don't know,
explained why you're there
in some kind of way with,
like, well, she's struggling
through her self-worth,
or some kind of fat
joke, or something.
It's just not there.
And you have like, "Hairspray,"
which paved the way,
but it was about her
size and overcoming it.
And "Margaritaville,"
there are different things
we talk about the size.
And this is the first time, I
think, in a Broadway musical,
where you have a
plus-sized woman
being the beautiful girl on
stage, and having a love story,
and falling in love.
And it actually-- the
lesbian love story
is just filled with
joy and discovery.
And we embrace it.
And everyone onstage
embraces us, which
is also sadly revolutionary.
So I love representing all
that and giving more voice
to lots of people.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Yeah, I mean, what I
love about the show is that
it takes these sort of tropes,
you know Elizabethan
language and characters
from the 14th the 15th
century, and queers them,
and in a very hilarious
and smart way.
But like, it is looking at the
show-- it's a very queer show.
And there's queer love,
which I think is beautiful,
Taylor, looking at you, like--
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Oh, yeah?
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah.
You know, just talk
to me a little bit
about the love
stories in the show.
And like, what does
that mean to have
a queer love story
represented on Broadway,
and many queer love stories?
Like, what's that
like for all of you?
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: I think
one of the coolest things
about our show is there
are many love stories.
And none of them are
really gender based at all.
Like, everyone's in
love with someone else.
And they either find out
it's not what they expected,
or it is what they expected.
Or they don't care whether it
was what they expected or not.
And I think that's what we-- we
have a character who's dressed
in drag for a lot of the show.
He's a male dressed as a female,
but the King and Queen both
find themselves
attracted to this person.
And along with
the young princess
is attracted to this person
no matter who they are.
And I think that's
really important,
and it feels so cool
to be a part of,
and to get to share that with
everyone, and like you said,
have people are at the stage
door see themselves on stage,
finally, in a positive--
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Celebrated.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: --way, yeah.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: I want to
ask about the reactions
to the show.
Peppermint, obviously,
hello, Season
9 of "RuPaul's Drag Race,"
which you were, you know--
PEPPERMINT: Season 9 runner-up
of "RuPaul's Drag Race."
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Queen to us.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yes, is there a
crossover in the audiences of--
do you see a lot of Drag
Race fans coming to the show?
PEPPERMINT: There must--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Clearly.
PEPPERMINT: I think so.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah.
PEPPERMINT: Yeah, Drag
Race is so mainstream now.
So there's definitely people,
especially at the stage door
which is really the opportunity
to meet people who obviously
have seen the show and hear
what they have to express,
and a lot of them say, I
watched you on Season 9.
And now I'm getting to see
you here, which is great.
So yeah, Drag Race is a
nice little intersection.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: When I saw the
show, Sasha Velour was there--
BONNIE MILLIGAN: What?
PEPPERMINT: Oh, yeah.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: --right
in front of us, yes.
Have other Drag Race
sisters of yours come--
PEPPERMINT: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: --come through?
PEPPERMINT: Yeah, and a
whole bunch more are coming--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Oh.
PEPPERMINT: --this-- I think
Drag Con is coming up--
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Oh yeah.
PEPPERMINT: So there's
going to be plenty.
But yeah, Sasha was
there, Bob the Drag Queen.
Thorgy Thor was here recently.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Yeah, Carmen.
PEPPERMINT: Yeah, they've all--
Carmen, yeah, they've
all come to support--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Oh, wow.
PEPPERMINT: --and
hopefully enjoy.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Which
is super great for us.
Super great for us.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: I think this
is a good time to take a pause.
Thank you--
BONNIE MILLIGAN: Thank you.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Thank You.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: --Taylor
and Bonnie for joining us.
They will be back at
the end of the show
to treat you guys to a--
PEPPERMINT: To kill you.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Yeah, to kill you.
PEPPERMINT: With their voices--
I shouldn't have said that.
Hi, security.
BONNIE MILLIGAN: No, no, no.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: To
slay you, perfect.
PEPPERMINT: Yes.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES: Yes.
PEPPERMINT: Yeah.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES:
With our voices.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: So I
want to invite up--
thank you, thank you both.
TAYLOR IMAN JONES:
Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Give them a hand.
It's my pleasure and
honor to invite up
a number of leaders
and activists
from our community to have
a discussion about exactly
what we're talking about,
representation, identity.
So please give a big, big
Google welcome to Rain Dove,
to Chase Strangio,
and Geena Rocero.
Yes, perfect, so
just to quickly give
bios, and then I want
to hear from all of you.
Rain, you were just on
the cover of Vogue Italia?
RAIN DOVE: Mhm.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Amazing,
we will talk about that.
And you're a model, a
longtime model in New York?
RAIN DOVE: Mhm.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Chase,
you are at the ACLU.
You are the first
out trans person,
first out trans attorney
the ACLU, is that right?
CHASE STRANGIO: I
mean, that we know of.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: That we know.
CHASE STRANGIO: Sure, Yeah.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: OK, great.
And Geena-- hey, Geena.
GEENA ROCERO: Hi.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: You're
a model, a producer,
and founder of media
advocacy group Gender Proud.
One more big hand for
all of our [INAUDIBLE]..
[APPLAUSE]
PEPPERMINT: Yeah!
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yes.
RAIN DOVE: And for
you, and for you.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: So
we've sort of been
talking a little
bit about identity,
and sort of representation.
And I want to sort of open
by posing to the group here,
like, how does your identity
show up in your art?
Can we talk a little bit about--
and you talked a little bit
about this as, like,
but I would love
to hear you talk more
about, does your identity
as a trans woman inform your
identity as a performer?
Let's start there.
PEPPERMINT: Yeah, for
a long time my drag--
I've been working in
New York as a drag
queen for 20-something years.
Most of that time
was before I had
really medically
transitioned, or even,
like, mentally transitioned.
And so for the longest time,
expressing myself as Peppermint
the queen was the only access
that I had to people affirming
this feminine,
female, this womanly
identity that I created.
And so my drag character
persona is really
just my trans identity,
kind of heightened.
And for a longest
time, that's all I had,
until eventually I was able
to wrap my head around more
and able to kind of, I don't
want to say separate the two,
but really cement my own
identity, my own self,
everyday, as a trans woman.
All the while I
kind of transitioned
underneath my drag persona.
So she, Peppermint
the drag queen
kind of protected me from
people judging me about,
why am I wearing this
clothing, or why do you still
have makeup on, and are
you going to a show,
and all these are questions
that I would sometimes get.
And also, for myself, it
allowed me kind of this space
to see me as I had--
to create myself, which I
had already done as a queen.
And so yeah, my art, my
first art, which is my drag--
and I still work
as a drag queen--
definitely is 100% made up of
everything that's Peppermint.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Oh, wow,
so do you think that--
I'm just interested
in this idea of,
like, you're using your drag as
a protection and as a shield.
Was that a conscious
thing for you?
Like, were you aware of
that while it was happening?
PEPPERMINT: Oh, yeah.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: OK.
PEPPERMINT: I mean,
yeah, in many ways.
I mean, I knew
that I wanted to--
I felt fabulous.
And I wanted to wear
these women's clothing,
and strut my stuff.
And obviously, you know, I have
a joy and love of performing,
so drag was the
perfect calling for me.
And there really wasn't any--
there weren't any other realms.
There was no other
Broadway roles
that were being written
that were supportive
of trans identities or even
gender nonconforming anything,
really, in my
experience, especially
as a black person auditioning.
It was pretty shallow
and narrow, I should say.
So I created this drag persona
to kind of include everything
that I always wanted to be.
And I knew that, for me, the
kind of fantasy of Peppermint
the drag queen was just
everything I always just wanted
to be, how I want to be seen.
And if I can't access
that in any other way,
then I'll do it onstage.
And I'll get paid for it.
And people are going to clap.
And that's kind of what
I started it out as.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Wow-- yeah, Geena?
GEENA ROCERO: I want
to add something
about what Peppermint was
saying about protection,
and that persona, and creating
that whole identity for us
by us.
Because it's more
than protection.
It's survival, right?
I mean, for so long,
we really needed
to find our way for us to find
platforms for ourselves, for us
to express ourselves, and
to find those safe spaces.
I mean, for me personally,
I was born and raised
in the Philippines.
We have this culture in the
Philippines of transgender
beauty pageants that happens
during the most traditional
Catholic religion tradition.
Irony is not lost on me.
But we did it.
So it's part of our culture.
So in a way, growing
up as a young person,
we needed to find those ways and
avenues to express ourselves.
So these trans
beauty pageants that
happens all over
the Philippines,
you know, this is
how I first learned
about myself at 15 years old.
This is how I first
learned how to really get
to know about who I
am and surround myself
with the community that
loved me and supported me.
And I found my chosen family.
So just to build up
on that finding ways
to protect ourselves is
also a way to survive,
and also building off
to that as people,
as communities, to
thrive as a community.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah, you
mentioned chosen families.
I just want to talk a
little bit about that.
I mean there's this idea
in the queer community
that we, as queer
people, often get
to choose our families
and the people
that we surround ourselves with.
Can you just talk
a little bit more
about what that means for you?
And this is-- and
you know, Chase,
we'd love to hear from you
too about how this shows up
in your in your activism
and your legal work.
CHASE STRANGIO:
Yeah, I mean, just
going back to the
initial question
and thinking about,
well, what does
it mean to show up as
ourselves in our art,
to sort of be a disruption of
the expectations that are often
imposed on us-- and so I sort
of like the idea of thinking
about law as art,
because we're narrative
storytellers as lawyers.
The work that we're doing is
always engaging with culture.
And so if you take me
showing up in my body
and being public about
that, making it visible--
you know, I was assigned
female at birth.
I don't have a very masculine,
traditionally masculine
presentation in the
courtroom or anywhere else.
And that is very
much a disruption
to the gender-normative
structures in the courtroom
and in the law.
And I think the law doesn't
really allow for nuance.
It tries to box
people into binaries.
It tries to tell
people that they
can't live intersectional,
nuanced, complex lives.
And so if we cede that
terrain to our opponents,
to the legal
structure, then we're
never going to make
space for people
to survive and step
into their existence.
And we have to be really careful
about, especially in sort
of conservative and
repressive political climates,
really giving up on the
idea that we have the power
to tell our own stories in
all the different places
that we show up.
And naming our bodies
and naming our truth
is, in and of
itself, a disruption
that is dangerous
for many people,
particularly people
of color, particularly
people who don't live
in binaries, people
who are bisexual, people
who are non-binary,
people who are people of
color, whose existence is
a threat to the power
structures that exist.
You know, it is
imperative that we
name the complexities
of our lives
and step into spaces where we're
not expected and allowed to be.
And so that's how
I try, as a lawyer,
to walk into the courtroom and
to tell stories of my clients
and myself so that
we aren't erased
from the power structures that
try very hard to erase people.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Yeah, I want-- yes.
[APPLAUSE]
RAIN DOVE: [INAUDIBLE]
That was amazing.
CHASE STRANGIO: Thanks.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah, I
mean, I totally hear you.
And I think just on that sort
of piece of naming, and claiming
your own identity
and personhood--
like, Rain, I heard
you in an interview,
you said you identify
as gender non-believing.
RAIN DOVE: Oh no, it's
not gender non-believing.
My identity is, I am I. So
I don't have any language.
I allow other people to use
whatever they feel is fit.
You know, we're
born into language.
And that language is tailored
to each person, specifically.
It's a unique experience.
In order for
language to work, you
have to have an understanding
of the history of the sound.
And if I said the
color red right now,
I guarantee everyone has a
different shade in their head.
So I don't police other
people's language for me.
When people-- like, I always
say a pronoun is just a sound.
And all I'm listening for
in that sound is positivity.
So you can use she,
he, it, one, they.
Whatever you want to use
for me is appropriate.
However, for some
people-- like, for me,
that's ultimate freedom.
I'm in this little
flesh-bound thing.
We don't look like ants.
And even ants look different
under a microscope.
So why are we
comparing each other?
Why are we homogenizing
each other?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
However, for some people,
finding their identity,
and having that
label, and having
that kind of stability in that
thing, it's their freedom.
Because they had to give
up so much, their families,
their careers, their lives,
maybe even lives of others,
in order to be able
to say, this history,
this history of this word is
a thing that I want to be.
So I don't police the way other
people identify themselves
either.
And I don't see other people
as imprisoning themselves.
In my work, I talk about gender
as, like, gender capitalism,
the idea that we've weaponized
this division in society,
he and she, as something that
you can capitalize on and make
money off from,
and sometimes even
have advantages given to you.
So a lot of my art actually
goes around comparative photo.
So I just [INAUDIBLE]
did an experiment
with domestic violence.
I went on to the New
York City subway trains.
And I presented as societally
very masculine, and then
societally very feminine.
And then I had two
other people with me.
And we yelled at each
other on the train,
culminating in a
slap across the face.
When people perceived
that there was
a female yelling at a
male, they'd be like, girl,
you get that guy.
You get him.
Oh boy, you're in trouble.
But the minute that
guy raised his voice,
people would literally grab me.
They would grab me.
They'd sometimes--
they would even hit me.
And we have a couple of times
where somebody was like, bro,
you need to chill out.
And they hit me.
And when I did it where it
looked like the same two
genders by societal perception
of what is male and female,
people just took out their
cell phones and recorded.
And it made it very
clear that it is actually
more advantageous to be a female
in a public situation in which
you are, you know,
you need help.
Whereas, if you're
a male, people
tend to sit back
a little bit more.
And with same-sex or
same-gender presentation,
we just don't have
enough education
to be able to
identify when somebody
is being abused at all.
People just didn't
know what to do.
So I mean, that's the
kind of experiment I do.
I take, like, the videos.
I show side by side.
It's just, I was
born into this body,
but by identifying
with one or the other,
why do I deserve less?
Why do I deserve less because
I might have more here,
or I definitely have more here?
You know, it doesn't
make any sense to me.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
What's your experience
been in modeling and in fashion?
What's that space
been like for you
as you've been sort of in
the community for years?
Like, how did you sort
of enter it, navigate it?
And how does it sort of
play out for you now?
RAIN DOVE: So basically,
in the modeling industry--
it's one of the few industries
in which men make more--
make less than women, by far.
And I model as everything,
whatever you put me in.
In the industry,
I find that there
is a lot more protection for
women for sexual harassment.
So when I do
male-perceived jobs--
is there water?
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah.
RAIN DOVE: Sorry about that.
But when I do
male-perceived jobs,
I tend to find that people
want me to take off more.
They want me to expose more.
And for male portfolios,
actually, there's
a lot more nudity,
but it's something
we don't talk about, because
men are supposed to be more
comfortable with their bodies.
And men are supposed to be able
to stand up for themselves.
However, with a lot of the women
stuff, the clothing that they
want you to wear, the
garments, even the heels
can be absolutely
crippling and damaging.
And it's so brutal.
You walk into a room,
people will flat out say,
you're fucking ugly.
Why did you even come here?
This is the women's casting.
Come here when you pick a team.
And the women are very
competitive with each other.
So they tend to put you down
a lot behind the scenes,
because it is so intense.
So the women, they're hungry.
They're told to lose weight.
I'm actually up right now for--
I just really got the
Louis Vuitton runway
show in campaign.
But--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, than, you.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yes.
RAIN DOVE: I'm very excited.
But it turns out it's
the women's show.
And they want me to lose 15
pounds before September 5th.
PEPPERMINT: Don't
drink any more water.
RAIN DOVE: I've lost six total.
And that's as far
as I'm going to go.
And they can fuck off.
[APPLAUSE]
But, yeah, I mean, I was
going to say, I really wanted
to, like, point out
Geena, because I mean,
Geena, you've been in
this industry a lot too.
And you know,
like, it's intense.
It's brutal.
GEENA ROCERO: Yeah, no, I
wanted to just put context
to what Rain was talking about.
It's important to
understand also
what had happened for so long.
I mean, personally, I now
produce documentaries, web
series, and stories that center
the narratives of the most
marginalized in our
community, specifically,
trans women of color,
especially created
by a trans woman of color.
For me, that was very
important, very critical,
both for representation and
the nuanced storytelling.
I was born and raised
in the Philippines.
And I moved to New York
in 2005 to pursue my dream
to be a model.
And in 2005, there is not an out
trans-identified fashion model.
So it's important to have the
context that we're having now.
For so many people, when
they see what's happening now
in fashion, gender non-binary,
gender fluid, all that stuff,
like, that was not the
case three years ago,
four years ago.
So when I moved in
New York City in 2005,
I made the decision to not
share to my model agent
that I'm trans, acknowledging
the degree of privilege
around that.
Because for so long,
I've had this--
there's many women,
pioneers who came
before me, women like Tracey
African Norman, Caroline
Cossey, Lauren
Foster, and many women
who paved the way for me
as a transgender model,
that when they got found
out, their careers basically
disappeared.
So in a way, they
were both a sense
of possibility of what
could happen for me,
but also a sense of fear,
that like, oh, if I actually
come out, that's what's
going to happen to me.
So I was working as a
model for about 10 years.
And you know, I was
working, doing commercials,
cover of magazines.
But every time I
would go home, I
would always feel so
scared and so paranoid
that, oh, the "New
York Post" page six
will find out that I'm trans.
My career would be over, so
I was living in paranoia.
So a lot of,
obviously, things that
has changed when it comes
to media representation.
But after almost 10 years of
doing that, I've had enough.
So I made the decision to
take ownership of my story.
I wanted to tell the world
and come out to the world.
So I decided to come out
in a TED Talk in 2014.
And even just 2014 to
2018, so much has happened.
I feel like it
feels so long ago,
because all of a sudden,
this conversation of gender--
"Time Magazine," Laverne Cox,
what we see on media right now,
"Pose" being written,
created, starred
by trans people of color,
centering the narrative.
So much has happened.
So it's important to
understand the context in which
where we're at right now.
Certainly, there's so much
more that needs to be done.
But it's important to
understand that there's so
many people, especially
the pioneers, who
suffered basically for paving
the way for so many people.
RAIN DOVE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah.
I want to talk about coming out.
And your TED talk, Geena, I
think is really beautiful.
Everyone should go watch it.
It was titled, "Why
I must come out."
And something about that word
"must" just sort of struck me.
So--
GEENA ROCERO: I didn't
title that talk by the way.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: OK.
GEENA ROCERO: So it's
important to even have that.
You know, but certainly, I now
have a different understanding
of this word coming out.
You know, because what
does that really--
for me, growing up in the
Philippines, I knew I was.
You know, I came
out to my mom when
I was wearing my t-shirt on
my head, telling my mom, mom,
this is my hair.
This is me coming out at 5.
I came out again at 15,
started joining pageant.
We want to have this nuanced
conversation about these words,
because we all deserve
that, you know,
to have those
conversations, especially
the cultural context in
which all of these things
kind of plays a part.
Certainly in 2014, so
much was happening.
I mean, Chase and
I, we're actually--
we haven't seen each
other in a while,
but we were even just talking
about, when did we meet?
When did we actually-- and
we actually met around 2014.
Because a lot of things
are happening in 2014 as we
all could remember.
It's "Time Magazine"
said this tipping point.
Obviously, that's
something to argue about.
But this word of coming out,
what does that really mean,
right?
CHASE STRANGIO:
Well, and also, just
to build off what Geena is
saying and what Rain said,
like, we all have
a responsibility
to understand that
gender is a system
that we're all complicit in.
And it leaves some people
imperiled by the system.
And others are
benefiting from it.
But the very concept
of coming out
is predicated, first, on
an assumption of cis-ness
and an assumption of
mono-sexual identity.
If we're not calling
it the question of,
well, what are we of
deploying every day
as the signifiers of gender,
of the assumptions of sort
of a bodily coherence--
and even the "Head Over
Heels" plays on this,
because it assumes that, if
you hear the word vagina,
you think woman, you hear the
word penis, you think man.
But those are political
choices that we're
making that then situate
very particular bodies,
and in vulnerable ways.
And we have a responsibility
to unpack that.
Because yes, a lot has
happened since 2014.
But I can tell you,
as a parent of a kid,
we're not doing a very good
job of dismantling gender.
We're actually doing a
catastrophically terrible job.
And we're all
responsible for that.
So I think we should
really pay attention
to how our language assumes
things about other people,
both in terms of their
bodies and in terms
of their attractions to others,
and who is left out by that.
Because it really does have
life-or-death consequences.
And I think we're all very much
responsible for building up
those systems.
RAIN DOVE: Wow.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Yeah, I mean, I love
what you said about coming
out, and just sort of, like,
just taking that idea
and sort of turning it
on its head a little bit.
I'm interested, though,
how that sort of plays out
in the public.
I mean, Peppermint, you
came out-- you, sort of,
came out very
publicly on Drag Race.
I just want to understand,
what was your relationship--
what is your relationship
to coming out?
Let's start there.
PEPPERMINT: Just as Geena
said, it's an ongoing process.
It's something that you
do over and over again.
Because coming out,
really, is, for me, it's
just telling people more
information about myself that's
always existed.
And so just as Geena
said, there could
have been many moments where I
revealed something about myself
that would have been very
telling about my identity,
whether I was a child,
or an adult, or what--
regardless of what
language I was using.
And so you know,
yeah, it's funny.
A lot of people
read, and people who
are fans of Drag Race who
hadn't known me personally
will say, oh, you came
out in 2016 as trans.
And for them, and I
guess for a lot of people
when you hear that, it means
that's when I transitioned,
realize personally
for myself who I was.
And that's not the case.
I've been living as a trans
woman publicly since 2012.
And I just wasn't on TV.
So yeah, I needed--
I felt the need to
have a conversation
with the people who were in
the room alone-- well, alone
with cameras.
And I didn't know
these humans, so I
wanted to talk to them
about my existence.
But it was more
than just me saying,
guys, I have something to
confess about my shame.
It wasn't that.
It really was, in
the context, as Geena
was saying, of trans-ness and
how it meets, and intersects,
and supports drag,
and always has.
Far too many times,
there's a lot
of people who-- just
as Rain was saying,
people want you
to make a choice.
You know, are you trans
or are you a drag queen?
Tell us which one so we'll know.
And, A, it's none of their
business, but B, it's--
you know, I don't see
the two as incongruent.
It's a job.
I'm a woman.
And I have a job.
Why do I have to choose
between those two things?
And so you know, that's--
the coming out thing has
always been an interesting kind
of language.
Because I always feel the need
to qualify and explain it.
Like, yeah, I came out
on "RuPaul's Drag Race,"
but you should know,
that's not really what it--
I didn't come out.
I did, but I didn't.
So it's complicated.
GEENA ROCERO: I think
there's a sense of--
I think the word
that's the through line
is sense of ownership, right?
PEPPERMINT: Mhm.
GEENA ROCERO: Because when we
talk about media, and media
that's being created,
whether it's in a Broadway
show, or a TV series,
or anything, a web
series, whatever
that is, there's
a sense of ownership that,
like, when trans people declare
ourselves, initially
the reaction
is like that you have to even
validate yourself even more.
You know, like you're not
believed that you are this.
Because for so long,
especially American media,
it's predicated
upon this thing of,
you don't own that identity,
because people were not
exposed to it.
Can you believe like, I found
this out about two months ago.
Jerry Springer
was just canceled.
So it's been on for that long.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: It's still on?
GEENA ROCERO: Isn't that crazy?
So I was born and raised
in the Philippines.
When I moved to the US--
we had transgender beauty
pageants on national TV
in the Philippines.
It doesn't mean it makes it--
you know, it's such a
progressive, accepted place.
But
We have this very mainstream
media representation
where people go to church.
They go home.
They watch the trans
beauty pageant.
That's what they did.
That's what we did.
But then when they
move to the US,
the first representation that
I saw on mainstream media
was Jerry Springer, which is
all about, like, you're this,
you're horrible this, a man,
woman I was just like, whoa.
And for so long,
American media is
predicated upon that, that we
don't own about our identity.
So all these things
that we're always
having to validate
ourselves is because
of this thing of ownership.
Obviously, here, we're
speaking about it
because we are who we are.
You know, we don't
need to go deeper into,
yes, we're educating,
but we don't
need to go to validate ourselves
that we are this human being.
Obviously we are.
But you know, I
think that it's--
I think a lot of the
things in representation
that's happening right
now, whether it's
in Hollywood,
whether it's, like,
who gets to produce
stories about trans people,
documentaries
about trans people,
or, like, who gets to play a
role, trans roles in Hollywood,
in any of these content
that we're seeing.
So obviously, there's
a lot more to go,
but the nuanced
conversation is everything.
But certainly, as someone who
produces content and stories,
you know there's a big
difference when there's
a trans person or gender
non-conforming people
behind, not just in front of the
camera, but behind the scenes.
I mean recently, Rain
was part of a documentary
that I did with Logo and
VH1 about the history
of transgender models.
When I was doing that project
as an executive producer,
I couldn't believe
that I was doing that.
Because for so long,
the representation--
I got to invite Tracey
Africa Norman, Lauren Foster,
Crimsona Kaiser-- these are the
woman that I mentioned before
that paved the way for me--
and sort of bring them
to the conversation,
and give them that space of
ownership about their stories
that, for so long, they were
denied, because they got
"outed."
That was the media
landscape for so long.
So I think this sense of
ownership about who we are,
or our abilities,
or our talent--
it's important to
understand that.
RAIN DOVE: I would like to
build on that a little bit
if I might.
Is that a thing?
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yes,
you should build on it.
We just want to open
it up to questions,
so if you have questions, from
the audience, please line up
at one of the mics
on either side.
Sorry to interrupt.
RAIN DOVE: No, of course--
yeah, so, I mean, first
of all, I was like,
am I supposed to be here?
Because I don't
identify as trans.
However, a lot of
times, people who
fall within the
non-binary spectrum
are seen as people within
the trans community.
But I do experience
a lot of transphobia.
And it was a really important
thing, I think, that you did.
It was really amazing.
I just want to build on the idea
of people behind the camera.
Right now, I just want to
put a big, like, warning out
to everyone.
There are a lot
of advertisements.
It is popular to have diversity
in your ads right now.
But just because you
see diversity in the ads
doesn't mean that they're
doing good things.
You really have to
research the products
that you're buying,
because you might say,
what I'm buying isn't
just a great product.
It's also making me
feel good because I
see Rain, or Geena, or
Peppermint on these like ads.
But they still support
animal testing.
They still support
factory sweatshop labor.
They still use palm oil.
They still use things that
deforest the rain forest.
People are trying to use our
anguish, our frustration,
our marginalization in
the feel-good Cinderella
story, that someone finally
sees us, to sell us something.
That is a beauty product
that has ugly practices.
And I really do want
to encourage you all,
like, if you take
something away from this,
it's to just continue
to educate yourself
and really do the work.
There are some really
great apps that
can scan the barcode
or even, like,
the UPC code on all products.
So if you have a
favorite product,
you can just use the app.
And it will tell you where
it sits on an ethical scale.
I know it might be
a little bit more
expensive for ethical
products, but that is
the cost of a clean conscience.
And we really have
to invest the money
in people who truly want
to invest back in us, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Thank you--
we have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for coming.
I want to know
what you guys think
about how we can raise the next
generation to kind of approach
this subject in
a better fashion.
I heard one of you
at least is a parent.
How would you raise
your kids, basically?
CHASE STRANGIO: Well--
PEPPERMINT: Let's examine
your parental skills.
CHASE STRANGIO:
Well, no, I mean,
I think that, in general,
it's so easy to be--
first of all, caretaking,
it is hard labor
that disproportionately
falls on women and people who
are fem-identified
for a lot of reasons,
and also people of color.
If you walk around a rich
white neighborhood in New York,
you'll see lots of
people of color caring
for older people
and younger people.
And I think we have to
be really conscious of,
like, the white
supremacy that's at play
in our caretaking in general.
So I just wanted to say
that, because that just,
it always strikes
me in New York.
I just think we
have to be really
conscious of the fact that
gender is a system, and that
every single day, we are
gendering people and behaviors,
and that there are costs
and consequences to that.
And so if we can do
anything, it would--
my sort of goal is
to urge us to stop
assuming coherence of bodies.
So for example, my child
doesn't have a concept
that body parts
correlate to genders.
It would make no sense, because
my child has seen me naked.
And that just-- I can't be
like, oh a penis is a boy thing,
but your dad doesn't have
one-- you know, and so
that, being really conscious,
and naming our bodies,
and then de-stabilizing
the idea.
Because if we think about
the violence against trans
and non-binary
communities, particularly
fems of color, women
and fems of color,
it's based on the
idea of a betrayal
of the truth of a body
that doesn't line up
with people's assumptions.
And if we don't start to get
rid of those assumptions,
we're going to keep
seeing this violence.
And just to go back to Geena's
point about representation,
you all may not have
consumed Jerry Springer,
but I bet you watched
"Silence of the Lambs,"
or "Ace Ventura," or
the "Crying Game."
And these are predicated
on the idea of,
oh my god, there's a penis.
And oh my god,
that's so shameful.
And our kids still
internalize that,
because we are
participating in the idea
that bodies are
coherently gendered
and a gender is not a system,
but a biological truth.
And if we don't
move away from that,
then I think we're just going
to keep entrenching the binary
and keep making it harder
for people to survive.
And that's on all of us.
Listen to your language.
How often do you say ladies?
How often you say dudes?
How often you say
girl parts, boy parts?
How often do you assume that
people in the men's bathroom
stand up to pee at a urinal?
What are the way in which
we're participating in this
and imposing that on a younger
generation and the people
that we caretake,
because we all do it.
We do it too, 100%.
GEENA ROCERO: It's
a lot of work,
but it's a worthy
endeavor to do, certainly,
because it affects everybody.
RAIN DOVE: Yeah, you've been
brainwashed since birth to use
a particular type of language.
I still make mistakes, actually.
I preach this thing of, like,
we need to drop and change
our language, but I still
make mistakes all the time.
I say dudes a lot, or
like, hey man, what's up?
And that comes right
out of my mouth.
It's this, like, natural thing.
So it's not something
that happens overnight.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Yeah,
thank you for that.
I want to go back
to something you
said, Geena, about sort of
who gets to play the roles,
like who gets to write the
stories and tell the stories.
And Peppermint,
obviously you are--
PEPPERMINT: I'm writing
all the stories.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: You're
writing all the stories.
PEPPERMINT: I've
written them all.
GEENA ROCERO: This
is the next show.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: As
the storyteller for--
PEPPERMINT: --for
history, for humanity--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: --for humanity--
CHASE STRANGIO: If only.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
No, I just kind of
want to ask that
question of, what
does it mean for you to
be a trans woman playing
a non-binary role on Broadway?
PEPPERMINT: It means everything.
And even just before
that, it was--
even though I've been
doing it for 20 years,
I was made to feel, after
so many of my contributions
and hard sweat, blood,
sweat, and tears
in the drag world
in New York City,
sometimes earning $50 a
show, traipsing to the bar
and having to take the
subway home, after all
of those dues that I
feel that I have paid,
I felt that I
didn't have support.
And marching across the Brooklyn
Bridge for marriage equality,
showing up for AIDS
and HIV research,
and education, and
prevention events,
and giving my time
to charity, which
I think charitable work is
a huge part of drag for me,
after doing all
those things, I felt
that I didn't have
a single friend
or ally in any single
one of those spaces
when I was dealing with
sorting out my trans-ness.
I didn't feel that my
jobs would be protected.
I worked seven days a
week in bars and clubs.
And I was in the room when
a very popular queen who
had since transitioned and was
kind of sorting all that out, I
was in the room when the manager
of the bar was, like, well
let's fire her, because
she's a trans woman now,
as if she doesn't have rent
to pay in New York and maybe
medical expenses.
That terrified me that I would
have to choose between the two.
And the reason why I really
went so strong into drag
was because I went to college
for musical theater performance
thinking that maybe I'd
have a career on Broadway.
And there was none
of me represented
in any of the rooms,
in any of the scripts.
In school, I was told
that I would have
to butch it up, and have to--
at best, you might
be able to play
a handful of characters that
are written as black gay guys.
And none of those
people were leads.
And so not that that was
what I was seeking, but just
to have an existence,
and being able to earn
a living in Broadway,
and then also
as a drag queen on
a major platform,
seemed impossible to me.
And I was faced with the very
real thought that I would have
to, if I wanted to do anything
more than pay my rent,
which is exactly what
I was doing with those
seven-day-a-wee, jobs, I
would have to investigate
and consider survival sex work.
This was just three years ago--
RAIN DOVE: Wow.
PEPPERMINT: --that
I would not be
able to continue my
medical transition,
or do anything more, have $1
to spend more than my rent.
After working seven
days a week, I'd
have to engage in
survival sex work.
And that was the
only option that I
thought that I had before
auditioning for Drag Race.
And even then, no one was
saying, come do Drag Race.
You're a trans woman.
We'll put you on.
No one was saying that.
I just-- I had
auditioned several times.
And I just said the last
time during the audition,
I'm just going to do my thing.
I probably won't
get on, who cares?
And obviously, I got on.
And so I didn't really,
to answer your question,
I didn't envision
any possibility
that I would ever be
on a Broadway stage
at all, let alone a principal,
and playing a character who
is self-aware, and reassured,
and confident in who they are,
and a very real
character in that way.
And representation does matter,
because when I was growing up,
the closest I had to seeing
myself was Richard Simmons.
And you know--
[LAUGHTER]
That's that.
So I'm so happy that we
have shows like "Pose,"
among other things
that are bubbling up,
and then that I have this role
on Broadway, which is rare now.
And it feels so good to be--
to have a moment in history.
But it also, at the same
time, as everyone on the panel
has said, it also reminds me
of how little opportunity there
has been for people like
me, and including myself.
And so yeah, did I
answer the question?
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Has the
publicness of this role
and of your time
on Drag Race, has
that changed your
understanding of allyship
and your feeling
of allyship at all?
PEPPERMINT: Yeah, I mean,
not those things alone.
I think the times changing
has clearly helped.
I think, for so long, we'd be
remiss by not acknowledging
that drag queens,
and trans folk,
and gender non-conforming
folk have always
been connected to the
queer community, obviously,
but gay bars and nightlife.
And I would entertain in Chelsea
and in Hell's Kitchen primarily
gay, white, male audiences,
every single night, giving my
all every single night,
all those seven nights.
And then you know, not one--
I just didn't feel like there
was any understanding at all,
or any sense of responsibility,
or any acknowledgment
that there is a privilege,
that even gay white men have.
Even though they are
a minority and we
are a family, within
the queer community,
there are moments where--
and certain things that I
will never have access to,
and certainly, in the
past, have never had.
And so it was very
upsetting to me
to march across that Brooklyn
Bridge for marriage equality.
I'm not getting married.
And even if I were,
my partner would not
be seen for who he says he is.
As a heterosexual
woman, a lot of people
would attack my
partner for being gay.
And even I've seen gay guys
in the presence of my partner
or trans women's partners say,
oh, you're really just gay.
You know what you like.
Just come over to our side.
And so that feels
like a betrayal.
And then in I think
2013, Island Nettles
was one of many
trans women of color
to be murdered
viciously on the street.
And there were several
vigils, and public moments
that were had.
And I went there.
There were no people from our
community that I could see.
There certainly weren't
any-- a lot of white faces
or gay white faces that I
knew of that were there.
And that felt like
a betrayal as well.
Like, I'm a part
of this community.
I've been entertaining you.
You know who I am.
And if I were murdered,
would you show up?
And that's a real thing.
But it's changing , because I'm
hearing conversations that are
different.
This conversation helps.
CHASE STRANGIO: But also,
I just want to say--
I mean, you're now put in
the position to say that.
I want to say, like,
as a white person,
I want to call on the
white queer community,
like, we consume the
black and brown labor
and then don't show up.
And you know, Peppermint has
been putting herself out there,
and educating
folks, and dancing,
and performing for people.
And then to not show
up, like, what is that?
And what is allyship really
mean in our community?
Because the LGBTQ community
is horrible at not showing up
for each other, and especially
when it comes to bi folks,
trans folks, and
non-binary people.
We erase and exclude, and
then benefit from their labor.
So I just want to say, like, we
can stand here and congratulate
ourselves.
Yes, we're doing better,
but not good enough.
And the fact that three years
ago, Peppermint could not
afford to basically
survive is a indictment
of how much work we
have to do internally.
And I just want
to say, like, you
shouldn't have to
name that, but I
feel like we should hold that.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Thank you all so much
for this really beautiful
and important conversation.
I wish we could go all day.
I hope we can continue
the conversation, just
as a community, and that we take
this with us out of this room.
And for those watching at home,
just really take these words
with you.
And yes, so before we
close, we do have a--
please give them
around of applause.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GEENA ROCERO: Thank
you for being here.
RAIN DOVE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN: And follow
them on social media.
Can we get-- should we
get handles real quick?
RAIN DOVE: Yeah.
PEPPERMINT: Peppermint247--
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Perfect.
PEPPERMINT: --on all platforms.
RAIN DOVE: RainDoveModel--
RainDove was taken.
Someone took it.
CHASE STRANGIO: I'm just
ChaseStrangio on Twitter.
GEENA ROCERO: I'm GeenaRocero,
that's G-E-E-N-A Rocero,
R-O-C-E-R-O. Get into it.
MICHAEL SHAYAN: I
love a good plug.
OK, so thank you all, again.
We are going to welcome back
Bonnie Milligan and Taylor
for a final performance.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
PEPPERMINT: Taylor Iman Jones.
MICHAEL SHAYAN:
Taylor Iman Jones.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SHAYAN: Taylor Iman
Jones, Bonnie Milligan,
and the fabulous Miss Ann Klein.
Keep it going.